sow
très fort sa fille de il sera donc là
non pas par sa fille et
là
alors qu'elle était au téléphone et donc
donc voilà on voit comment bas après ce
drame on continue à vivre les commandes
comment a
une âme sol et la leçon son enfant
sans la maman et film intéressant dans
cette partie aussi sur cette fausse
piste où on sait pas trop pourquoi il
est serré laquelle au début on pense et
cela qu'est ce qui est dit dont ils ont
divorcé et puis petit à petit on
comprend qu'il ya quelque chose d'autre
et jusqu'à 40 en dhr le message qu'elle
a laissée au moment où c'est c'est une
je faisais arié elmaleh
voilà qui est un acteur
dont je suis le travail depuis assez
longtemps maintenant qui est
il est très grand très grand et j'aime
bien
cette petite fille d'un petit
et anti côté en fait petit côté chaplin
dans leur équipe et puis il est très dur
le risque
de voir un registre en plus pas
forcément comédie un peu plus dramatique
ouais moi j'ai jamais créée à dire là ça
veut dire est que c'est là où on pose
les comédiens on peut se faire imposer
les personnages pardon on pose
on n'a pas besoin de beaucoup de choses
puis moi j'ai dédié aux dialogues assez
particulier en fait qu'ils sont à la
fois très simple qui paraissent en tout
cas seul quand on lui dit qu'ils sont un
peu
dans le quotidien donc voilà je ne fais
pas des directs ré écrit qui sonne pas
très écrit à la compétition ils le sont
mais c'est dieu s'est dit fier d'écrire
est simple
ce film est intéressant pour moi les
ravages les drames que peuvent poser
juste un coup de fil un coup de fil
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait par 50
fois par jour à des coups de fil comme
ça aujourd'hui on peut découper pour
n'importe quoi en plus composer coup je
suis pour dire gérer
moi je suis d'une génération où
on n'avait pas de téléphone portable
c'est peut-être bien aussi après on
faisait différemment je suis très
content d'avoir importé après faut
savoir l'utiliser il doit y avoir un
code de la route du portable